American Horror Story season 8 has
finally come to a close with was
arguably one of the most tied together
seasons of a television show ever
episode 10 apocalypse then finally
brought everything full circle and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
the ins and outs of the season finale
there will of course be heavy spoilers
so if you don't want to know what
happens and I suggest you turn off now
for everyone else welcome to the channel
I'm definition and I Runa so you don't
have to by the end of season 8 we see
that the apocalypse has been reversed
and the world has been saved however in
doing so a new Antichrist has been
created that will undoubtedly play a
huge part in season 9 but how do we get
there well there's several events that
led to the final timeline correction
thanks to a bunch of intricately laced
plans by Cordelia both Coko and Mallory
had their memories erased and replace
the outpost 3 to ensure that there were
some witches that still remained at the
end of the Apocalypse
this allowed the coven to remain dormant
until necessary which is when they
returned and bestowed power upon Mallory
once more there's some huge moments that
follow which involve Cordelia
sacrificing herself in order to revive
Mallory who stabbed death by her now
mutant ex-boyfriend this sacrifice
allowed Mallory to travel back in time
to the day that Michael aged 10 years
overnight and stop him before he became
unstoppable it's some terminate a
timeline fix that sees Constance kicked
Michael out on the day that he killed a
priest instead of sheltering and
nurturing him Michael distraught that
Constance as abandoned him runs out into
the road where he's hit by a car that
has Mallory behind the wheel if only
only had have done that then we never
would have gotten the terrible terrible
Terminator Genisys anyway in his dying
breaths
Michael begs Constance to take him to
murder house to die so that you'll be
able to become an amoral ghost Constance
however refuses this and tells him to go
to hell which is when the character dies
it's sort of the usual would you go back
in time and kill Hitler if you could
debate and I'm glad that the creators of
American Horror Story say yes yes I
would
Mallory then let's events play out as
they normally would and returns to study
as a student once more amongst the
witches because it's now 2015 three
years before the nuclear blast Cordelia
is still alive as other students who
were slain
by Michael in the future with Mallory
stopping the apocalypse she's now on
good terms with several underworld
demons and manages to negotiate Misty's
revival while some characters are at a
loss everything seems fine by the finale
so it's a bittersweet finish
however it's not over yet and with time
being reversed this also means that
Emily and Tim were never poisoned by the
apples that led to their downfall whilst
they seem pretty unimportant to the
overall storyline of season 8 we do
indeed learn that the creator's may have
further plans for them in season 9 Tim
earlier in the show was haunted by
mysterious whispers and the number 666
that appeared on his bathroom mirror now
that the two are free of the apocalypse
they meet and have a son named Devon who
they come home to one day to discover
that he's just as evil as Michael was
outside the sky turns red and Anton
LaVey and his Church of Satan Cardinals
arrive at the house to stay that this is
the day that they'd be waiting for Eagle
Eye viewers will recognize this phrase
for when they did the same thing to
Michael in the altered timeline and it
hints that things are still going to go
ahead with a new Antichrist as Michael
stated the prophecy is inevitable and it
seems like Satan has a plan for every
scenario well some of the events now
could not happen the way that they were
meant to including a vast majority of
hotel we can assume that these events
may have played out similarly due to the
fact that Tim and Emily still met which
showcases that the universe will find a
way to correct itself and that the
apocalypse may still unwind further down
the line season 9 has room to pretty
much do what it wants to now and it will
be interesting to see how it plays out
with a new foundation and villain at the
helm so what are your thoughts on the
finale of season 8 did you enjoy it and
what are your top five seasons of the
show comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of TV's other huge show The
Walking Dead which will be linked at the
end of this episode this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
Definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]